Зазвичай питають: Вас примусили?
Ні. Мене ніхто не примушував.
В  чому сенс зовнішньої політики президента Зеленського?
Президент Зеленський хоче миру з РФ.
Чи вірити Ви в те, що "нормандська четвірка" це може зробити?
Особисто я не вірю в благі наміри президента РФ.
Які стосунки у України наразі зі Сполученими Штатами Америки?
Є певний вакуум.
Як Вас сприймали дипломати з Росії?
По-різному. Вони трошки втратили пильність.
Чому заступниця міністра закордонних справ Україна Олена Зеркаль йде у відставку?
Хто буде замість неї представляти інтереси України в міжнародних судах проти Росії?
Що очікувати від "нормандської зустрічі"
та чи може бути вирішено питання транзиту російського газу через Україну з 1 січня?
Про це ми говоримо з Оленою Зеркаль. Доброго дня.
Доброго дня.
Ви вже написали заяву про відставку. Чи підписали Вашу заяву?
Це все ще процес. Заява зараз знаходиться вже у держсекретаря.
Я збираюся потрапити до міністра.
Знаєте, у таких випадках зазвичай питають. Вас примусили?
Ні. Мене ніхто не примушував. Я прийняла самостійне рішення.
Вам якось натякнули, що Вам не слід працювати далі?
Знаєте, дуже часто не треба натякати.
Коли ти довго працюєш, ти розумієш, що або ти робиш щось,
що приносить задоволення, де ти бачиш, що ти можеш досягти результатів.
Або ти просто працюєш над папірцями.
Не в моєму випадку працювати над папірцями.
Мені здається, що ми всі дуже змінили свій образ роботи.
І він змінився дуже суттєво порівняно з тим, як ми працювали раніше.
Чи відчули Ви якусь небезпеку,
приміром, з боку Росії через свої висловлювання на міжнародній арені?
Кожного разу, коли ми представляємо свою позицію в Гаазі чи в Гамбурзі,
це зазвичай є заходи безпеки, які вживаються місцевими службами
для захисту тих, хто бере участь в процесах.
Дійсно, коли ми виступали влітку в Гаазі, були підвищені заходи безпеки,
зважаючи на те, що в них були певні підозри щодо можливих інцидентів.
Ми дійсно тримаємо все достатньо конфіденційно.
Тому, звичайно, в нас були випадки,
коли одного разу пограбували двох моїх співробітників в один день.
І все, що в них забрали, це комп’ютери і всю електроніку. Більше нічого.
Ви колись відчували, що за Вами ведеться спостереження з боку російських спецслужб?
Чи-то українських?
Мій телефон регулярно відчуває, що йому дуже важко працювати.
Все решта, я намагаюся не звертати  на це увагу.
Росія аплодує, можливо, через Вашу відставку?
Чому їм буде краще? Навпаки, вони не розраховують на те, що їм буде краще.
Ми намагаємося притягнути Росію до відповідальності
за невиконання конвенції про заборону фінансування тероризму
і конвенції про ліквідацію всіх форм расової дискримінації
Друга справа - це справа, яка стосується України як прибережної держави.
І в цій справі мова йде про всі права України в Чорному, Азовському морі і в Керченській протоці.
І воно дійсно дуже важливо для нас,
оскільки ми доводимо, що Росія фактично експропріювала наші права.
Це стосується і свободи навігації, і рибальства, і охорони культурної спадщини.
Це дуже велика справа.
Ну, і третя справа, яку ми почали в цьому році,
це справа про порушення імунітету військових кораблів і членів екіпажу.
Чи можете підтвердити чи спростувати, що українським дипломатам
заборонили або натякнули на те, що не слід так критикувати дії Росії, як це було раніше?
Щойно виступаючи в Берліні, я дозволила собі критикувати Росію і називати речі своїми іменами.
Я маю на увазі інших дипломатів…
Мені це невідомо.
Ви можете сказати, в чому сенс зовнішньої політики президента Зеленського?
Президент Зеленський хоче миру з РФ. Він неодноразово про це заявляв.
І він його якраз і буде демонструвати під час "норманської зустрічі".
Я думаю, що всі вже побачили, що в його розумінні мир. Це припинення вогню.
Це те, щоб повернулися всі наші українці, які зараз незаконно перебувають і в РФ, і в Криму.
Це налагодження відносин з РФ. Це укладання нових договорів. Це все, про що він говорить.
Чому Ви не вважаєте, що це доцільно?
Ні, я вважаю, що це доцільно. Я просто не вірю в справжність намірів президента РФ.
Можливо, президент Зеленський хоче миру з РФ, оскільки він розуміє, що не всі в Європі
мають одностайну позицію по відношенню до Росії.
І не всі хочуть з нею сваритися?
Абсолютно можливо.
Особливо глядячи на позицію на президента Макрона,
який прямо заявляє, що в інтересах Франції це дружба з РФ.
Справа в тому, як ми будемо досягати цієї дружби, на яких умовах.
Якщо він говорить про те, що ми забезпечимо територіальну цілісність і суверенітет,
і що буде відновлено
наш територіальний суверенітет над Кримом і над Донбасом і Луганськом, то це одне.
Але в мене виникають великі сумніви щодо того, що президент РФ погодиться на те, що Крим - не їх.
Наразі прокуратура активізувалися щодо перевірки можливої держзради високопосадовців,
які були причетні або мали відношення до переходу українських кораблів через Керченську затоку.
Для Вас це негативний сигнал?
Для мене це негативний сигнал з точки зору того, що це розслідування веде ДБР.
І для мене важливо, щоб воно його вело об’єктивно, щоб не було ніякого політичного впливу.
Тому що будь який політичний вплив і формування "правильної" позиції
дійсно може мати негативні наслідки.
Весь наратив, який стосується того, що це була провокація, був придуманий в Москві.
І я дуже не хочу сумніватися в тому, що люди, які працюють у ДБР,
використовують наратив, який народжений в Москві.
На 9 грудня запланована "нормандська зустріч".
Яке має бути прийнято рішення, на Ваш погляд?
Звичайно, що у всіх сторін власні інтереси.
Я сподіваюся, що рішення буде збалансованим - на користь України.
Принаймні, буде чітко окреслено, як Росія буде виводити війська,
важке озброєння, як буде відбуватися всі безпекові заходи на цій території,
як буде гарантуватися те, що там можуть бути проведені вибори
відповідно до українського законодавства і відповідно до стандартів ОБСЄ.
Чи вірити Ви в те, що "нормандська четвірка" це може зробити?
Особисто я не вірю в благі наміри президента РФ.
Франція і ФРН зараз знаходяться не в найкращому стані відносини між собою, це правда .
Бо останні заяви президента Макрона
викликали дуже негативну реакцію в Німеччині, і це не тільки канцлер.
І взагалі Макрон дуже зосереджений зараз на внутрішніх проблемах, а  не на зовнішніх.
Що стосується США, то США споглядають.
Я скептично налаштована. Саме тому, зважаючи на мій скептицизм, час йти.
Які стосунки у України наразі зі Сполученими Штатами Америки?
Зараз фактично є певний вакуум.
Звичайно, порівняно з тим, який в нас був інтенсивний діалог в минулі роки,
то зараз, зважаючи на те, що всі, хто займався українським питанням, зайняті імпічментом,
інтенсивність цього діалогу значно зменшилася.
І питання, які ми обговорюємо,
і візити, які відбуваються, не можна порівняти з тим, як було раніше.
"Газпром" заявив, що з 1 січня в нього не буде підстав для постачання газу в напрямку України,
оскільки поки немає транзитного договору.
Що мала б зробити Україна? Як Ви думаєте?
Я думаю, що Газпром мав би щось зробити.
Ми два роки розповідали їм, що таке європейське законодавство.
Тут не існує жодних проблем технічних з укладанням цього контракту, окрім політичних,
і небажання визнавати рішення суду, якій присудили Україні виграш в 2 млрд 560 млн.
Ваш прогноз, що буде з транзитом після 1 січня?
Я не думаю , що ані "Газпром", ані "Нафтогаз", ані будь хто в Європі
зацікавлений в тому, що була б криза і не було газу.
Хоча я думаю, що "Газпром" може бути зацікавлений в цьому.
Запаси газу "Газпрому" в Європі
знаходяться постійно на високому рівні, і вони продовжують закачувати в підземні сховища
і їм є чим торгувати в Європі.
І це може бути дуже прибутковим.
Навіть якщо це зашкодить їх іміджу. Але для них імідж не є принциповим.
Чи слід було Києву віддавати Росії свідка Цемаха?
Для мене кожний свідок в цій справі є важливим.
Так само, як і для голландців.
Які наслідки Ви вже побачили? Негативні…
Парламент Нідерландів
замовив незалежне розслідування
щодо того, як відбувалося взагалі закриття неба в Росії
і в Україні під час того, як знаходився літак  в повітрі, і до того, як знаходився літак в повітрі.
Це не розслідування, це дослідження.
Але для них важливо мати зараз всю інформацію.
До цього вони просто вірили у те, що все відбувалося, що написано,
є таким, що не потребує додаткового доказу.
Зараз їм хочеться мати більш широку картину, як Росія закривали свій простір, і як реагували ми.
І чи знали ми взагалі про те, що Росія постачала "Бук" на територію України.
Але я знаю, як це відбувалося.
І я знаю, що в нас не було
там жодної установки "Бук".
В нас не було підстав вважати тоді,
що там є такі установки, які можуть загрожувати цивільній авіації.
А росіяни, постаючи туди "Буки", вже розуміли це і закривали свій повітряний простір.
Які перспективи визнання Росії винною у катастрофі?
Шанс притягнути всіх винних в катастрофі до відповідальності є і дуже високий.
В нас дуже ґрунтовна позиція в міжнародному суді ООН,
де ми доводимо , що російські посадові особи свідомо постачали систему "Бук" в Україну,
розуміючи, що вони не будуть здатні зробити, якось відрізнити в повітрі різні цілі.
Тому, коли лунають гучні заяви про те, що вони не стрілили по цивільному літаку,
вони дійсно могли не стріляти  по цивільному літаку, але просто система була неповна поставлена.
І тому система не могла відрізнити: цивільний літак або військовий.
І ті, хто постачали це, не могли це не знати.
Чим це загрожує Росії?
Росії це загрожує тим, що вона буде визнана
країною, яка не забезпечує боротьбу  з фінансуванням тероризму.
І російські посадові особи будуть визнані винними в фінансуванні тероризму.
Що буде відбуватися з РФ в 22-23 році, я не знаю.
Але я вірю в те, що неможливо уникнути відповідальності.
"Північний потік-2" може зупинити санкції проти Росії з боку Америки.  Наскільки це реалістично?
Зараз наші американські друзі в Конгресі
і в Сенаті дають 75%, що відповідні положення будуть прийняті до кінця цього року.
Щодо того, наскільки це реалістично, подивимося. Залишилося не так багато.
Які санкції можуть подіяти на Росію?
Санкції проти компаній, які забезпечують прокладання труб.
Їх дуже мало, і вони всі відомі, і вони всі в цьому переліку, який додається до цього проекту.
Позиція Європи "Північному потоку-2" неодностайна. В чому Україна може програти?
"Північний потік-2" не може бути просто російським газогоном,
який не підпадає під дію європейського законодавства.
Зараз відбулися зміни до законодавства в Німеччині,
які дають німецькому регулятору широке поле для застосування норм.
Звичайно, ми дуже уважно слідкуємо за тим, як само німецький регулятор застосує ці норми.
Європейська комісія, а також країни Балтики,
і інші країни, які, в принципі, втратять дуже багато,
якщо "Північний потік-2" почне працювати,
а  український маршрут буде виключений з постачання газу в Європу.
Фінансування Росією тероризму в Україні, расова дискримінація в Криму.
Справа України проти Росії в Міжнародному суді ООН буде розглянута.
На підставі рішення суду Росію можуть визнати країною, що фінансує тероризм.
Але це пройде ще 2 роки.
Чи зможе МЗС України витримати цей пресинг, котрий, можливо, слід очікувати з боку Росії?
Вперше застосовується конвенція про заборону фінансування тероризму.
І вперше на фазу розгляду по суті переходить справа, яка стосується расової дискримінації.
Крім того, Росія буде вперше відповідати за порушення міжнародного права.
Чи здатне МЗС? Ніхто не вірив, що ми  взагалі здатні дійти до міжнародного суду ООН. Здатні.
Бо нове покоління вже виросло не в СРСР, не з радянським мисленням, а самостійним.
І я дуже пишаюся тими людьми, з якими я працюю. Вони молоді, але вони дуже віддані.
Можливо, рішення суду підтвердить, те, що Росія - країна, котра фінансує тероризм.
Чим це загрожує Росії?
Росія може визнати порушення і надати всі гарантії того, що ці порушення
не повторяться, як це передбачено міжнародним правом.
А також компенсувати всі витрати або інші видатки, пов’язані з фінансуванням тероризму.
Вони витрачають також шалені гроші на цей захист.
І вони намагаються зробити все, щоб не бути визнаними винними.
Для них це буде шалений удар по репутації і не тільки по репутації.
Можливо, Ви та Ваша команда рахувала, яку суму може вимагати Україна від Росії?
Я можу сказати, що підрахунки всі робляться на останній стадії.
Думаєте, Росія колись може це сплатити, яка б там сума не була?
Вони весь час думають, що вийдуть сухими з води,
але кількість справ і кількість боргів, які вони мають сплатити, буде зростати.
Це невідворотній процес.
Зараз вони будуть робити дуже багато чого, і намагатися повернути контроль за ситуацією,
розуміючи, що вони програли всі справи, які розглядалися по забезпеченню інвестицій в Криму.
Вони не думали, що арбітражі встануть на позицію українських компаній і будуть захищати інвестиції,
які українські компанії робили в Криму, а сталося по-іншому.
За 5 років відстоювання інтересів України на міжнародній арені,
Ви могли бачити трансформацію сприйняття?
5 років тому ми всі просили якоїсь допомоги.
Ніхто не розумів, якої допомоги, але всі просили.
І навіть були дуже смішні випадки, коли ми просили якоїсь допомоги, а нам так тихо говорили:
"Ми вам вже надали".
Зараз всі процеси вони більш зрозумілі.
Ми не звертаємося по допомогу аби звернутися по допомогу.
Ми вже говоримо, що це можемо зробити самі.
Тут нам потрібна ваша допомога технічна або практична,
і ми можемо досягнути того то. До нас відносяться більш цивілізовано.
Країни ЄС за останні 5 років могли більше допомогти зупинити російську агресію
проти України? Чи згодні Ви з цим?
Не можу погодитися, бо у кран ЄС немає спільної безпекової і оборонної політики,
вона тільки створюється.
Що стосується економічного зростання, інвестицій і решти питань, можливо, і так.
Але дуже багато залежало і від України,
чи створено в нас було нормальний бізнес-клімат, чи захищалися інвестиції,
чи відповідно працювали інституції, які мали забезпечувати верховенство права.
Тобто багато питань і всередині ЄС, і назовні.
Ви сказали, що виконали усі завдання на своєї посаді. Ваша головна перемога?
О, в мене декілька перемог. Я не можу сказати, яка з них головна.
Для нас була велика перемога це те, що, незважаючи на війну на нашій території,
ми змогли отримати безвізовий режим з ЄС.
І міжнародні суди.
Для кожного юриста це дуже важлива перемога -
бути представником держави й отримати перемогу там.
Це дійсно перемога в моєму житті.
Жінка-дипломатка в Україні. Наскільки це складно?
Змінилася культура всередині в МЗС.
Я сподіваюся, що це незворотне, і що вже не буде повернення назад до
мислення, що жінка не може бути послом, що жінка не може представляти країну на якомусь
важливому майданчику, бо вона просто жінка, емоційно нестабільна.
Я думаю, що для моїх колег-жінок це дуже важливі зміни,
вони, я сподіваюся, вже не відчувають себе обмеженими в кар’єрних можливостях.
Як Вас сприймали дипломати з Росії?
По-різному.
Часто я використовували їх зверхнє ставлення до себе
для того, щоб вони трошки втратили пильність.
І це виходило, бо вони ж чоловіки.
Там мускуліність продовжує превалювати.
Чому Вам наразі більше цікава громадська діяльність?
Тим більше в такій темі, як розвиток людського капіталу?
Тому, що я бачу проблему в цій сфері.
Я бачу, що ми не приділяли уваги взагалі наступним поколінням.
І люди, які приходять, молоді, вони, навіть коли хочуть це роби ти, але в них немає навичок.
І ніхто не займається розвитком цих навичок.
І навіть тут в середині МЗС, незважаючи, що є дипломатична академія,
є майданчик для того, щоб розвивати ці навички,
все рівно це відбувається не в сучасному вигляді.
Коли працюють зовсім інші механізми, не стільки
класичної освіти, скільки опрацювання якихось скілз.
Ви би хотіли зробити політичну кар’єру?
В мене є проблема з прийняттям того, що я фактично вже стала політиком,
тому що я 5 років працювала на політичній посаді.
І тому що мої заяви і стейтменти мої сприймаються, як політичні.
Що стосується подальшого - не знаю, як буде складатися - подивимось.
Писати книгу про те, як Ви працювали в МЗС будете?
О, ні. Я дуже скептично до цього відношуся.
Я вважаю, що вже стільки людей пишуть різні книжки…, що...
Ні.  Але, що розповісти, дійсно є.
Можливо, колись. Коли я буду на пенсії, як Мадлен Олбрайт, я буду писати книжки.
Дуже дякую Вам.
Дякую.